So, okay, let's know a bit about this
app. You said you had an app, the
website, £16,000 sisters. What is the
app used for? Because we want to
obviously get the app again and there is
funds that's needed uh for one year. I
think it's just around £4,000. Can you
just tell because there's people here
who want to help, who want to support,
who who want to, you know, invest in the
So, what would it entail? So when
somebody's donating, what would what
service would that give to the um
>> So so the app really is uh is a
technology that allows us to manage a
safe space for Muslim women,
>> a um halal compliance if you like
>> place where there's no fitnner but
sisters can connect they can have
courses um they have free material um
they can download some of the uh Quran
or TJID courses that we
They have online exams so they can
practice their knowledge. Um it also
gives other sisters uh a space for them
to create their own groups and courses.
>> Um the idea is that we ensure the
quality of what the sisters are
learning. So we had one sister for
example in rever and returners who
became Muslim
>> um and she had nowhere else to turn to.
it's actually in the UK and she ended up
going to various
um not so uh authentic should I say uh
organizations and she came to us
learning you know really uh um I don't I
don't know how to describe it. She she
learned Islam wrong and we had to
explain the differences between sects
and groups and what they are and what
the sunnah was. So we'd like to create a
a space for our sisters who are looking
to learn about Islam. A space that they
they can be assured they're going to
learn about the authentic Islam that
sallallahu alaihi wasallam shared with
us. Um and a space to learn other
things. So it's not just about learning
your dean, but we do we do programs to
help sisters who are having problems
with HR and they have no con consultants
in HR. Um and we do uh programs with
lawyers to give them advice about issues
about home. Um so there's various
different things and and programs that
we run on the program.
>> So it's it's a platform that when it
comes to all these other course you're
doing the Quran etc.
>> Sorry. So, so the the program so
basically the the app will be used to
have these sisters like a little hub
where they can all come and then from
there the the you channel them back to
to the Quran things to do the exams or
for example if sister are going through
certain issues etc. Okay, that's
interesting.
>> So it's actually so so the way we we
explain it is it's a social learning
platform for Muslim women. So there's
the social element and then there's the
learning element. So we grow together
and we socialize together. social
learning platform for Muslim women.
>> I'm just SLMM. I'm just trying to make
her work so we can Okay, good. Perfect.
So, um, alhamdulillah when it comes al
it's mainly your focus is the Quran.
>> Yes. The the the core of our work is
obviously Islam.
>> Um, and we spend a lot of time and
energy building structured toued
programs. We've been very successful.
Alhamdulillah.
>> We've been running it since 2016. Um the
teachers are scholars uh and they most
of them I'd say 90% of them are in Mecca
or Medina. Um one of the the girls that
works with us was actually a teacher in
Omula University in Mecca. Um and the
the concept behind our Ted program was
to give sisters access to female
scholars. It's easier for men uh back
then at least to travel to Saudi and
study the dean. Um but a sister at home
with five children and having to work um
that accessibility was very minimum. So
we wanted to open those doors and create
teachers at home. One of the sisters for
example that was on our course,
alhamdulillah, she completed I think
three years on our courses and she now
where at that time she taught 300
sisters in Bangladesh for free. So the
idea is to build this knowledge at home
uh in in every home if we can.
>> That's good because we're also working
we want to work with you with the Salah
Pro um project which is and we also want
to teach Quran to new Muslims or Muslims
who don't know. So our one's really
basic. It's the three andah fat we want
every Muslim who may not and may not
know for whatever reason or revert
subhan Allah to memorize and we do want
to we are still discussing we want to
work with you to get them to if they
want to further develop their you know
reading etc. So we are working closely
with you that as well in so it's like a
joint venture that we're doing. Subhan
Allah. So for for our donors who are
watching this as well it is a project
that we are working with sister and
stuff on that as well. That's that's
fantastic. Okay. So for that app we need
around $4,000.
>> Yeah. Yes, that is and that's on the
deal
>> and we've got about 4 days.
>> Yes, we don't have very long to do that.
>> We don't have very long. We've got 4
days
to raise the amount, guys. Inshallah.
And whatever amount you give, brothers
and sisters, do not belittle the amount.
Don't look don't no donation is too
small. One not done is to